it's one of the world's most famous
skyscrapers soaring 103 stories above
midtown Manhattan the Empire State
Building is a staple of the New York
City skyline and a building in
transition Empire State Realty Trust CEO
Tony Malkin has plowed a half a billion
dollars into energy improvements I
loaded up the floors with
state-of-the-art enhancements all to
make this a high-tech hub for companies
like clothing distributor lien Fung USA
I said to the head of the operation you
know you know you're offending me if you
won't come and at least look at the
Empire State Building I won't give you
another square foot in any of my
buildings and they came and they looked
and they really fell in love with it so
lien fong rlf USA they're your largest
tenant here well so I love USA's
actually our largest tenant throughout
the portfolio we have Kody LinkedIn
shutter stocks a two floor tenant in
this building famous to tourists for its
sweeping views of Manhattan it's what
most people never see that's
transforming this New York City landmark
when we did all the insulation as part
of the energy efficiency when we did the
energy efficient elevators all the
energy efficient lighting and everything
else what we realized is we don't have
to do all those things we have plenty of
power in the building we're going to
retrofit the chillers instead of
replacing them and what do we end up
with some of this stuff is 50 60 70
years old original 1931 steam station
we're at the wind tunnel right okay so
tell me what this is about
well this is this is fresh air makeup
and so we need to bring fresh air into
the building so this is fresh air which
comes into the building from the third
floor works its way under the building
and actually supplies fresh air to a
couple of the underground levels and to
the stores that are have lower levels in
the building above the wind tunnel
Construction is underway for a white
tablecloth restaurant and a fourteen
thousand five hundred square foot gym
exclusively for tenants so this is what
this area is this is so we've got free
weights across the wall we've got
stretching and other weights here
the concept here is your typical
employee office worker has an hour for
lunch so they want to come in spend no
more than 45 minutes of the gym which
gives some 15 minutes to grab food and
get back to the desk now we're going to
go a hundred and third floor which is
truly VIP treatment
beautiful tell me what life is been like
after the IPO it's wonderful life is
much more simple biggest lessons learned
the biggest lesson learned was that that
you can take on about anything which
anyone else would tell you is nearly
impossible if you plan you have patience
and you have stamina my name is Phil
being up here sorry I feel like I
probably got about 80 emails on my
blackberry since we've been walking
around I really need to get to them